le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais communément
appelé les soldats du feu les pompiers
interviennent auprès des populations de
différentes façons du gros feux de forêt
au petit bébé ces hommes et ces femmes
dévouées interviennent toujours avec la
conviction de vouloir aider et soutenir
son prochain pour intervenir au mieux il
est nécessaire que les pompiers soient
le mieux équipé possible qu'ils
disposent des meilleures conditions de
travail
comment améliorer ses conditions de
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
christian lebon et sergent-chef aux 10
de saint lô
comme ses collègues christian exerce son
métier avec beaucoup de passion l'esprit
d'équipé la solidarité et le respect des
autres sont partis de ses valeurs
propres à tous les pompiers
ces hommes rencontrent chaque jour des
situations compliquées des problèmes
difficiles à résoudre
malgré leur entraînement régulier et les
stages de perfectionnement
les pompiers doivent tout de même faire
preuve d'improvisation car chaque
intervention est différente
c'est pour cette raison que le conseil
général soutient le sdiss de la réunion
en investissant entre autres dans des vs
avez véhicule de secours et d'assistance
aux victimes afin d'augmenter les
chances de sauver des réunionnais donc
il ya du matériel de nouvelles
technologies qui nous est parvenu on la
ddsv savez dispose de la climatisation
donc vraiment un confort aussi bien pour
la victime que pour nous intervenons
nous avons des tables et des perfusions
qui permet aussi bien aux médecins du
smur qu'à nous-mêmes de travailler dans
de meilleures conditions
donc en fait le but c'est vraiment
d'optimiser
le potentiel mois là sur le véhicule ont
travaillé dans de très bonnes conditions
d'une part avoir une meilleure prise en
charge est assurée aussi
la santé et la sécurité de notre
personnel
voilà ce cap que nous avons également
aussi depuis la crise requins
du matériel qui peut nouveau pour nous
c'est des gars au delà tourniquet on a
également vu des sangles
une somme à renier pour sembler une
victime lors d' accidents de la voie
publique
c'est une matière d'éducation de
dernière génération donc les techniques
ont été améliorés pour qu'on soit
performant et qu'on diminue aussi ce
phénomène de stress qui est impermanent
puisque chaque intervention est
différente
inattendu donc le fait d'avoir du
matériel de qualité nous permet aussi
d'être plus se rassurent intervention
alors ce qu'on a également s'éteint
encore dernière génération qui permet
pendant le transport de lier
et
le point des déformations de la route
vous confondre la victime donc c'est sur
ressorts mais vraiment nous qui avons
connu les anciens
vous savez sourire que la victime y'a
rien à voir
elle est pratiquement horizontale tout
sur tout le monde de l'art où on aille
sur les chemins un peu
dans les écarts ou sûr
tout sur eux des fois deux voies on est
vraiment dans des costumes
cet équipement moderne est certes très
coûteux mais ce n'est pas du luxe
il n'y a pas de prix pour augmenter les
chances de sauver des vies la présidente
du conseil général nassimah dindar met
un point d'honneur à ce que toutes les
casernes et tous les pompiers de la
réunion puisse bénéficier du meilleur
équipement possible la sécurité des
réunionnais est très importante pour le
sdi c'est aussi pour le conseil général
il faut savoir qu'il y à 3000 pompiers
aujourd'hui qui travaillent au quotidien
pour assurer cette sécurité et qu'un
pompier intervient toutes les 12 minutes
par jour c'est dire l'importance
qu'occupe dans la vie au quotidien
ces pompiers et le travail qu'il réalise
il faut leur rendre un hommage
particulier
c'est pour cela que le conseil général
nous avons mis des moyens
supplémentaires aux dix réunions à en
livrant des véhicules de haut niveau
pour avoir des soutiens
performant pour ce travail au quotidien
dix-neuf nouveaux véhicules et jusqu'à
2017 il y aura donc 40 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront budgétés pour
que nous puissions pas seulement mieux
équipés mais aussi réhabiliter et
construire de nouvelles casernes donc
vraiment des conditions de travail
optimisé pour avoir une sécurité des
réunionnais optimisé elle aussi chaque
année la démographie de la réunion
évolue le nombre d'habitants augmente
les immeubles et les routes se
multiplient ces paramètres augmente
aussi les risques d'incendié d'accident
il est donc nécessaire et indispensable
que les services d aide à la population
dispose du meilleur équipement possible
pour optimiser les interventions les
compétences humaines ne manque pas de
même que le dévouement et le
professionnalisme mais chaque seconde de
gagnés dans une intervention peut sauver
une victime
un temps de réaction qui peut être
améliorée grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
optimiser les moyens techniques pour les
pompiers de la réunion c'est améliorer
le service aux personnes en difficulté
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais